all right well next one is a brand new
one as well we have the best Deez Nuts
moment because uh as I said at the
beginning there was kind of a
Renaissance of Deez Nuts jokes among uh
trash taste yeah and it kind of spread
throughout yeah so I think this started
from the charity stream when I got these
nuts about 36 million times uh and a big
part of this year was us traveling to
conventions and getting to interact with
you guys and what we realized after
interacting with you guys is that you
guys just love to Deez Nuts us you're
all children yeah it was like it was
like a competition about who could wind
up with getting the best Deez Nuts
moment on the boys I swear there was a
moment for for a brief moment where
among the the trash days fan base where
it was like it was kind of like a badge
of honor if you were like yeah I I Deez
Nuts God IRL and everyone's like whoa oh
did it
but yeah there were a lot of Deez Nuts
uh so let's go through all of them yeah
so so we have we have the truck couldn't
these nuts what happened at ax to Connor
which anime protagonist has the power
sneak thieves
I don't watch enough anime to know this
one
sneak sneak these nuts oh my God
yeah yeah baby is that even a good one
is it even a good one sneak these nuts
not to mention that like Mouse like kind
of said it before yeah yeah yeah Mouse
knew it was coming Connor was like oh I
don't know what's going on man oh next
one is my personal favorite uh my load
on your face which isn't technically a
Deez Nuts but uh this one was a new one
for us I guess these nuts is more of the
Cadence yeah yeah the Cadence yeah last
question today
um
do you know what Milo is
n't it like most Southeastern countries
yeah
uh I mean it's pretty popular in
Thailand yeah yeah
um do you know what it is
not four it's a chocolate chocolate well
there's the second part uh to this
answer it says yeah my load in your face
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I think what makes us stand up my mind
so much was that we just had an entire
conversation taking it seriously it
wasn't a quick one it was just the oh
yeah I know Milo I and we just had a
full-on [__] conversation about it
didn't expect it I did not expect that
at all and uh that was that was
incredible uh the next one is uh
probably the most recent one which is uh
Kawaii con Deez Nuts
I don't know
[Music]
Paul Connor you likely die
[Applause]
there's just the the Vigor of which he
said it is so intense
you know sometimes you have to say these
nuts joke in all caps respect to this
guy because this guy set the tone for
this panel yeah everyone he was the
first one yeah he was the first question
that was asked he also came to us later
and nailed everything like you said like
the Bangkok name yeah yeah yeah yeah
wash Town name yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the man was very talented yeah and
then uh this one is one of our own
getting uh this is when we least
expected it have you tried Rock
what's that
[Applause]
um
why is it always me why am I always the
one people are asking these questions to
none of these moments are my favorite
all of them suck none of them should win
I personally just want to give it to
rock on just because Kevin just no one
was expecting it and Kevin just nailed
me I thought I was safe I trusted you
Kevin you were in the circle of trust
now you are out of this never trust
Australians that's the rule of thumb uh
Australians man but uh yeah all all
really good nominations uh and some had
some different buildups I I gotta either
give it to uh Kevin or Milo yeah because
Milo I literally did not see that one
coming I think the trucking One's Gonna
Win there you think so it's it was the
one that was shared the most oh [__] all
right let's find out
let's find out we go the best Deez Nuts
of the pass here is
oh all right I mean
he did uh he did start the uh Trend it
was just because it was like the room
was like a 1 000 capacity Filled Room it
was like intense and yeah it was just a
it was a it was it was a lot yeah yeah
all right uh what were the top two
nine points oh [__] yeah see I told you
guys okay
all second followed by myself
that was a long build up for that one
yeah that's what made it so good yeah
it's the payoff the payoff made it worse
well let's hope we don't have enough for
this category next year all right uh
because I don't want to get these nuts
okay now we are we are aware guys so
next time we go to a convention we're
looking out we've got to work extra hard
you've got to work extra hard if you
want to get us next time the next award
is a classic the best drip Awards who
will win the best trip I mean we had so
many guests who just came in with the
drip as well so I think there's going to
be a few guests to nominate or I'm not
sure about that but let's look at the
nomination Shelly Connor Connor that's
me with a suit yeah Joey the one time
Conor's not wearing uh the uh
Joey gone with the Miss soccer look yeah
Chris not sure about that Anthony yeah
all right that's the nomination some
tough competitions look at that you
can't beat the energy from one picture I
think is strong enough that it could
take it could take it yeah I like how my
dad's never been on any four content
aside from like one aside from one
picture that just got posted online or
some [__] the hat takes a lot of
confidence yeah yeah only your dad can
rock off that I'll be honest when I when
he first started wearing that uh because
he first started like wearing that uh in
like my teenage years I was like Dad Dad
are you gonna really wear a fedora come
on dad really but like now that now that
I've grown up
with the suit it wasn't
yeah I remember this picture just
getting shared all over the Reddit so
that that's not what I was expecting but
who will it be who is the best Street
hopefully it's not Chris ladies and
gentlemen the winner of Best rip 2023 is
dance
congratulations Dad you probably don't
even know you got nominated
you probably didn't even know the
internet were talking about you Dad but
uh congratulations
yeah everyone was talking about your dad
one picture and uh you won best uh who
was the top three top three
oh my God 55 oh [__] God followed by
Chris with 14.5 how what
yeah all right well that was best drip
well deserved congratulations God stat
uh Gone what's the next category the
next category is we awarded best trip of
course we have to oh no laziest oh no as
well all right lazy strip and the
laziest trip nominations oh Connor
understandable Joey okay me yes and
Chris is that it
as much as I do think Connor has the
laziest rip I kind of want Chris Chris
has even lazier drip yeah I'd say Chris
is lazy I love meme Christmas wears polo
shirts all black t-shirts yeah that's
all he wears yeah I mean uh Chris hasn't
won an awards uh this year yet so you've
got to give him a dollar we gotta give
him a dub right but there can only be
one winner out of the four of us let's
find out and the winner for laziest trip
goes to
Connor
hey let's go [__] don't worry Connor
this year I'll I'll change you okay then
I went by a lot yeah
52. so at least tell me Chris got second
Chris got a second yeah
I'm lazy it's called consistent there's
a difference okay lazy would be putting
no effort I put a lot of effort into
making sure I wear the same thing I put
a lot of effort into buying the same
shirts yeah I do I do all right well
thank you all right
congratulations sure let's move on
though to the next one which is uh
Pinnacle of trash days the best argument
yes lots of arguments this year as
always on traffic I always have
arguments let's look back on some of our
best arguments shall we so we have again
live mode versus dark mode that was uh
that wasn't even an argument that was
just a beating if I'm being honest I
mean uh it was me versus the worlds uh
some of the returning hot takes from
earlier Attack on Titan is a macro anime
from Joey Charlie prefers earlier JoJo
parts that that was kind of that's an
argument that expanded across the years
yeah it finally got resolved with it
finally got resolved in this one one
piece being political which is true this
is true and the rice versus bread
argument oh god I've also got Cindy and
Connor arguing about wine which is just
like it's not even a trash tasting
that's just the daily thing yeah and uh
Fearless agreeing with all the boys bad
takes
what what did he agree with it again I
know he agreed with me on not watching
Arcane he agreed with you on I think
skipping cutscenes yeah uh skipping
cutscenes in video games yeah and he
agreed with you on cutting off the cross
of a pizza oh yeah yeah yeah we saw him
do that I was like that's actually
[__] yeah it was [__] up literally
cut out I finally found a fellow cross
lover and then he had to agree with
Connor on uh skipping cut scenes and I
was like is he smart
and he didn't watch Arcane because he's
smart no that's bad uh so who do you
think's gonna win
awesome it's hard this is actually a
really tough one yeah I do think one of
guards ticks might take it though I'm
secretly hoping light movers dark mode
gets two Dobbs versus Brad could also be
up there yeah sure I think the uh Attack
on Titan is a Mecca anime could also be
up there that was a pretty [__]
heated argument that got Joey to say
that Mac uh that Abra is what I'm making
around me stop reminding me I don't like
the Heat of the Moment which I'm just
like oh no I don't know I know what that
came from don't make me eat my words do
you know how I know like you know how I
know it's a good argument when we get
heated enough to say something really
[__] that's how most of our [__]
tastes come from we just get so heated
we just say a really really shitty taste
that's true so they can only be one
winner only one yes only one let's find
out the winner of the best argument of
the year goes to
Attack on Titan is a maker thanks
wow I'm shocked at one honestly well
what did you think was gonna win I
thought it could have been one of God's
spicy takes sure the hills he was dying
on were not worth it
one of the top three
point one percent oh twenty one point
that was close he was agreeing with all
the boys
wow
so it was in the running yeah
yeah I'd say shock this one honestly but
it was a great argument one of the best
friends we'd had yeah it was fun to see
Joey say something just could find out
it was like Instant Karma compilation
doesn't have samurais in it